hey youtubers it's Charlie so the
unthinkable just happened george RR
martin just released new Song of Ice and
Fire content as part of a book called
dangerous women takes place about 150
years before the events that are
happening on the show right now
since a lot of you probably haven't had
the chance to read it yet I'm not gonna
do spoilers but I will do my top five
things to look forward to I'll also do a
non-spoilery review but you seriously
have to buy this book there are dragons
everywhere in it so top 5 things to look
forward to in this book number 5 the
Targaryen family tree so the story takes
place about 150 years before the events
that are happening right now in the Song
of Ice and Fire and on the show that
means that the Targaryen that this story
focuses on would be like Daenerys great
great great great you know grandmother
six times removed basically because the
Targaryen sweer still in power at the
time there's a lot of them to remember
on the show Daenerys is basically like
the last of our kind almost as far as
you know number four casual use of
dragons so obviously a dragon is a big
deal even back in the time that this is
taking place but because there are so
many of them the Targaryen use them for
everything from transportation to
killing peasants if you remember during
season one visitors actually says they
keep all the skulls from dead dragons
inside the iron throne room obviously
now the Baratheon's are in power so they
put all the skulls underneath in the
dungeons but they still store all those
skulls so the skulls from all the
dragons that died during this event the
dance of the dragons are actually stored
beneath the Iron Throne right now number
three allegiances are very different
between the Great Houses so on the show
right now say for instance House Stark
and House Lannister are big enemies but
back 150 years ago it was very very
different so it's a really funny jokes
to position based on the current
allegiances on the show right now
especially during the war of the five
kings
number two the death of the Dragons so
obviously on the show right now there
are no dragons with the exception of
Daenerys dragons most of them actually
died during this event the dance of the
Dragons either died in battle or were
murdered so if you remember in King's
Landing they actually have a dragon pit
where they used to store all the dragons
they used to hatch new dragons because
they were chained up that was actually a
place where a lot of Dragons ended up
getting murdered by people in King's
Landing it still exists on the show
right now but it's just kind of a burnt
husk version of itself and if you
believe the rumors there's a lot of
wildfire stored beneath that dragon pit
tube and
my number one thing to look forward to
the dance of the Dragons the actual lore
of the Dragons so it's a civil war
between the Targaryen but obviously they
kind of pull in the rest of Westeros
into this conflict the really awesome
thing about this that you don't see on
Game of Thrones right now though is
dragon writers dragon writers are
actually a special group of people that
have Targaryen blood you have to have
like this special Jedi mind powers to be
able to bond with dragons so even if
you're a Targaryen bastard you can still
become a dragon rider if you have the
right mojo a lot of people have actually
been asking me who I think are gonna end
up writing Daenerys dragons because
obviously she's going to be writing one
of them at some point they're not quite
big enough yet but hopefully during
winds of winter and a dream of spring
will actually get to see people riding
those dragons so if you haven't read the
story yet you can buy it super cheap on
Amazon I'll put a link in the
description I actually bought it for my
iPad I don't want to post any pirate
links just because I really want george
RR martin to be my friend someday
that'll never ever happen but i just
don't want to take the chance so here's
a non-spoilery review of this short
story it's just the short story the
dance of the dragons the book that it
appears in is actually much longer I
can't tell you how excited I got about
when I found out about this short story
it's been so long since I read dance of
dragons it's probably gonna be at least
another year or two before we see winds
of winter so if you are a big fan of the
Game of Thrones books you obviously this
is on auto buy but if you're on the
fence it actually has this amazing
old-time eNOS to it that you don't
really get in the show it's almost like
you're learning about Westerosi history
from a professor I could only imagine
how awesome it would be to take that
class in school
Westeros history 101 speaking of Game of
Thrones we're actually due for a trailer
pretty soon we got one around this time
last year but they might hold it to next
year don't worry though until it comes
I'll still be doing my weekly character
videos be sure to post in the comments
who you want to talk about next I've
done a bunch of characters also have a
link to the playlist that I've done so
far so in other news I've had a bunch of
extra videos and a bunch of stuff I had
to take care of this week so I'm a
little bit behind but I still have an
American Horror Story that I'm working
on for tomorrow morning and a Legend of
Korra video so I'll have two videos on
Saturday right now click here to get
that American Horror Story video I'll
add the annotation as soon as I post the
video tomorrow and click here to get my
previous Game of Thrones video thanks so
much for watching high fives for reading
now go buy the book
you